-Welcome to the show.
-Thank you for having me.
-I really appreciate you
making the time.
So you have been an undocumented
person for 25 years.
-Yes.
-And when you wrote your boo
that won the Pulitzer,
you said "Notes of
an Undocumented Citizen."
Why was it important for you
to have "citizen" in the title
-Well, actually, I ended u
winning the Pulitzer
when I was a reporter
for "The Washington Post."
-Gotcha.
-It's not for the book,
but thank you.
-And I feel like you were
overlooked for the book
and I'm gonna
make a big point of it
next time I talk to my frien
Bob Pulitzer.
[ Laughter ]
-You've got to love America,
though.
I ended winning
a part of a Pulitzer
but I can't get a Green Card
-Yeah.
-Right?
So, there's no process for
undocumented immigrants like me,
who have lived here 26 years
next month
to actually legalize our statu
and follow a process.
Actually, I was watching
the debate tonight.
And I actually started thinkin
that, coming on the show,
I want to actually
make an announcement.
I think after tonight,
I am deciding to run for
President of the United States
of America.
-Alright, yeah. Why not?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-On behalf of all
the undocumented immigrant
in the country.
I'm totally kidding.
Totally kidding.
Because the reality is,
undocumented immigrants like m
can't even vote for an election,
much less participate in one
-You showed up when you were
12 years old
from the Philippines,
and you did not realize
until you were 16 and tried to
get a driver's license
that you lacked documentation.
Is that how it worked out?
-Yeah, that was in 1997.
Only 13 states allow
undocumented immigrants
to drive.
So I found out when I was 16
There was no Google.
It's not like I can Google this.
And I'm Filipino.
And whenever the media sai
anything about illegal people,
it was always about Mexico
By the way, if you see
an Asian-looking person
with a Latino name,
it means they're Filipino.
[ Laughter ]
That's a little hint from me
There's 4 million of us
in America.
So, I thought I may be
the only non-Mexican
undocumented immigrant
in this country.
Then thankfully I was a studen
in high school,
and my teacher, Mrs. Door, sai
I asked too many
annoying questions
and I should do this thing
called journalism.
And then I found out that
when you become a journalist
you get a byline.
So, like, your name is
on a piece of paper.
so I thought if I can't be her
because I don't have
the right papers,
what if my name is on the paper?
Like, this book actually has
a Library of Congress number
Like, I don't have a Green Card,
but the book is documented
and I'm not.
[ Laughter ]
-That's all right.
-But what is that about, right
Like, actually, for me, now that
immigration is, like,
the central topic
in this election,
I think there's an opportunity
for us to really educate peopl
about what the issue is,
and what really a lot of
the politicians and even peopl
in the mainstream media
is not really talking about.
-What are they getting wrong
When you read coverage about it,
when you watch a debate
like tonight,
what do you feel like people are
getting wrong
when they talk about
the immigration debate?
-Well, the number-one thing is
the fact that there is --
The number-one question I ge
asked all the time is
"Why can't you just get legal?
As if all I have to do is
flip a switch and poof,
I'm an American
stealing your welfare, right
And even tonight
during the debate,
when they talked about
undocumented immigrants
and healthcare,
undocumented workers like me
actually contribute
billions of dollars
in taxes and Social Security
Like, I have paid so much taxe
this past tax season,
I should be a Republican.
-Yeah.
-Right?
So, we pay into the system
that deports and detains us.
Like, so what is that about?
And the fact is,
in the media, even now,
and I'm really sorry
to say this,
even "The Washington Post" and
"The New York Times" still refer
to people like me as illegal
So Define American has actuall
been at the forefront of
actually challenging
how news organizations
and then how television show
portray immigrants like me
-Talk about Define American,
and when you started it,
and obviously those were
a couple of the goals,
but how you go about trying to
get people to listen.
-Well, to be honest,
I'm only one story, right?
Like, if I counted all
the undocumented white peopl
that I meet at Starbucks -
-That's where
they would hang out.
And they tell me
they're undocumented,
and usually we don't talk abou
undocumented white immigrant
or even undocumented black
immigrants
from Africa or the Caribbean
The reality is
the fastest-growing
undocumented population
are coming from Asia,
not from Latin America.
I actually think owe
the Mexican people an apolog
for having made this issue
just about Mexican people
and just about Latin America
Right?
[ Applause ]
What? There's like 56 millio
Latin people in this country
And the majority of them
have been here for decades
if not centuries.
Like, I don't know,
when California used to be
part of Mexico.
So, to me, really, our goal is
how do we get people
to get this issue
out of this border Mexican box
that we have locked it in.
And for us, storytelling
is the way to do that.
So if you're undocumented an
you want to share your story
if you're white, black,
if you're an engineer
or if you're a farmer,
go to our website --
defineamerican.com
and tell us your story
and help us get this issue
out of this box
that we have relegated it in
-Well, I'm so glad
you're doing that.
Thank you so much
for making the time tonight.
And it's just great
to talk to anybody about
this issue, especially you
Jose Antonio Vargas, everybody